Hey ladies it's Joanna here so this
workout is a targeted workout focusing
mainly on your hips so for those of you
who might be self-conscious in regards
to having bulge around the hip area this
workout will help to tone your hips up
giving you firmer and also solid looking
hips okay so there will be six exercises
we will mix it up between strength
training and also how your workout so
it's all about your hips so get them
moving each workout will be for 30
seconds long with 10 seconds in between
so it's a very short rest basically I
want you to do each workout back-to-back
with minimal rest okay so the first
workout it's going to be a curtsy lunge
then shoot it with a pod toes point up
forward and hands by your hips and I
wanted to cross over lunch whew your
hips and twist and cross good it's all
about the hip movement so twist lunch
crossover lunge and feel your glutes and
each side of your hip as well okay kid
so remember to always keep your knees
bent and go low twist and lunge okay it
is a targeted workout it's all about
working on your legs your hips and your
core as well keep going lunch good rest
it out ten seconds second work out sumo
squat pulses so Stan why okay toes
pointed out I want you to just give me
small pulses okay so just lift it up
down and lift it up that's it tiptoe
tiptoe okay go low stay low maintain
this position and go low and tiptoe you
will also feel on your inner thighs good
keep lower Kate do not come up right now
stay low and point very nice keep going
tiptoe point it nice lift your heels off
to your inner thighs feel your glutes
the outer part of your glutes working
and rest it out in and out squat again
it's all about small movements but you
were really feeling so start now okay
start with in order to step out step in
step out and step in the goal here is to
stay low okay the more you stay low the
more your legs will be on fire
good stay low for your hips out and down
good in and out very nice keep going
in and out out and in nice go low and
feel your thigh spinning and rest it out
grab your net let's move on to
spider-man okay so get down onto the mat
low and let's go into a plank and let's
go spider-man crunch it good nice move
your hips bring your knee to your elbow
very good
there you go knee touching the elbow
keeping your back flat and crunching on
your outer hips okay so spread it open
it wide bring it to the side very good
keep going nice last few more and now
let's get into a low playing okay so
start no I want you to give me plank hip
dip so in a low plank and just dip side
to side good so again it's all about the
hips moving and twisting and targeting
those muscles good dip to your left to
your right to your left and to your
right
halfway there very good
nice and last one more on each side
good and now give me the final workout
Andy Hobbs all right so start in a high
plank
I want to hop to the left and to the
right okay let's go hop left center
right center left center right center
good keep going this is a little bit of
cardio could get your heart rate up
center left center right center good ten
more seconds right left right and keep
going you're strong last few more and
that is all the six exercises get back
up let's not stop now let's get back
into curtsy lunge all right so stand
straight and let's go lunch to your side
to your side good
so non-stop eight minutes
good that's your side and go deep okay
every time you dig deep that's when you
feel your muscles working even more dig
deep knee almost touching the floor and
come back up
nice down up down and up last one and
rest it up ten precious seconds okay now
stand white sumo squat with pulses okay
white let's go down and up tiptoe tiptoe
tiptoe good
if you can't stand wider tiptoe and
tiptoe very nice good do unifies burning
your outer thighs look straight ahead
open up your chest look straight nice
keep going
my thighs are burning my inner thighs
are burning but that's the burn you want
keep going
point last two more point point and
ten precious seconds and now in and out
okay so start low legs together and step
out let's go out in out and in small
steps remember keep your body low look
straight ahead
okay open up your chest do not hunch
forward
okay so open up your chest point your
butt back push your butt back open and
close whoo
my eyes are burning let's go ladies work
on those hips work on them
good go deep go low and rest it up
spider-man plank okay get down onto the
floor ready or not let's go knee to
elbow good crunch it crunch stay strong
strong upper body strong core strong
hips so spread your legs to the side
spread it bring your knee to your elbow
okay the more you spread it the more you
will be working on your hips and also
your obliques to tone them up keep going
spread last one more and rest plank dips
right now okay so get into a low plank
and give me a nice deep dips
okay good let's go left to right touch
gently relax the shoulders look ahead
look straight ahead breathe deep dip and
did good left to right do not lift your
body too high up maintain a flat plank
position
very good deep deep and nice do more
and rest it up you got one last workout
okay which is going to be playing hops
all right bring up your heart rate and
high plank let's go left center right
good come on last 30 seconds and you are
done
keep going nav Center right Oh pace your
breathing breathe in and out you have 10
seconds left
do not stop right now I know you're
feeling the burn and that is exactly
what I want you to feel that's right
rest is out you should be sweating
slightly you should feel that your hips
your legs and your core are working
together as a unit and that you will
only get stronger okay ladies so do this
workout at least two to three times
weekly we're gonna hit muscles remember
it's all about combining strength and
it's a cardio workout breathe if you
want to challenge yourself repeat the
entire circuit once more if you're
sweating like me give this video a
thumbs up share this video with your
friends get them to sweat with you and
don't forget to subscribe to my youtube
channel for a lot more crazy workout
challenges and all kinds of workout to
turn up on your arms your hips your core
basically your entire body I have lots
of healthy recipes as well so do check
them out
all the best